i
[Música]
ah
en plena segunda ola de la pandemia el
personal sanitario reclama refuerzos en
materia de recursos humanos y es que
según los datos de la ocde españa cuenta
con poco personal sanitario respecto a
algunos de sus vecinos europeos por
ejemplo en españa se cuenta con a 30
profesionales sanitarios por cada 1000
habitantes una cifra que es doblada por
países como francia o como alemania sin
embargo el principal déficit se
encuentra en el ámbito de la enfermería
es por eso que durante la primera ola de
la pandemia durante el estado de alarma
el ministerio de sanidad movilizó
alrededor de 50.000 profesionales
sanitarios entre los que se encontraban
estudiantes de los últimos cursos de
enfermería y de medicina y personal que
estaba ya en edad de jubilación sin
embargo como sucedió aquí en madrid
muchos de estos contratos
extraordinarios no se renovaron cuando
pasó la primera ola de la pandemia pero
esta misma semana el gobierno española
acaba de decretar una medida que permite
la incorporación de alrededor de 10 mil
profesionales sanitarios al sistema de
salud entre titulados españoles sin
plaza fija y titulados extracomunitarios
[Música]
un informe del año pasado del ministerio
de salud se establecía en 16 por cada
10.000 habitantes el número de médicos
en chile muy por debajo de la media de
la ocde que se sitúa en 34 a pesar de
los esfuerzos realizados en los últimos
años también reforzar tanto a los
médicos generalistas como los
intensivistas durante la pandemia
supimos también que el número de médicos
especialistas en cuidados intensivos en
urgencias siempre con pulmonar se
situaba en menos de tres por cada
100.000 habitantes sin embargo desde el
ministerio de salud donde no existen
datos oficiales sobre el ratio de
médicos durante la pandemia si nos
informaron de que se ha realizado un
esfuerzo importante en reforzar la red
de salud tanto privada como pública que
ha funcionado de forma unitaria
incorporando a personas retiradas a
estudiantes de últimos años de medicina
de importantes universidades chilenas y
también se flexibilizó las exigencias a
los médicos extranjeros que en algunas
partes del país han jugado un rol muy
importante en la lucha contra la
pandemia
[Música]
de acuerdo a la organización mundial de
la salud uruguay se encuentra en séptimo
lugar en el mundo en relación a la
cantidad de médicos por habitantes
uruguay cuenta con cinco médicos cada
mil habitantes pero menos de dos
enfermeros cada mil habitantes una
situación que dicen los expertos debe
mejorarse y por ello las autoridades
sanitarias están tomando medidas hace
varios años para revertirla
en relación al coronavirus las
autoridades sanitarias junto con
donaciones de empresas privadas lo que
implementaron fue más centros de
tratamiento intensivo en el interior del
país ya que en varias ciudades carecían
de los mismos si bien uruguay tenía 21
centros cada 100.000 habitantes y es lo
que la organización mundial de la salud
recomienda al parecer en algunos puntos
del país se tomaron esas decisiones
[Música]